oops I hit record before I was always
prepared hello guys welcome to the first
ask ID episode of 2015 I took your
questions from Twitter so if you're not
following me on Twitter make sure you
follow me on Twitter because that's
usually where I take my questions for
YouTube so if you have some questions
ask them there anyway lips uh let's get
started on the ask IJ questions boy I'm
really excited about this this is just
great
I don't really remember the last time
was that I did an ask I J episode you
guys tell me because you know everything
you know more than me this is by Alonzo
who wants to know what the most
embarrassing moment is that I've ever
had here's the thing I do a lot of
embarrassing things but usually it's for
camera and I'm filming it so I know I'm
embarrassing myself but embarrassing
myself for the better good of the
Internet and to make you guys laugh
recently I still get I still can't get
over this I were the target and I ripped
my pants and in one ripped a little bit
and I was like mmm I think they might
have ripped like ran into one of those
little and cap things and I was like
alright so when I get in the car I sit
down and it's just like and I felt my
skin on the seat and I knew things were
bad all that time that I was walking
around Target I didn't really actually
realize my butt crack was hanging out
and here's the problem if well I mean I
think you can probably figure out how a
thumb works but when you hear where
lenders really there's nothing covering
anything the struggle was real kind of
embarrassing but I don't think anybody
saw unless they had the security footage
but nobody knows what target I was at I
think the secret was safe with uh with
me with me with you so don't tell
anybody
Katie wants to know I'm going to be
getting the Apple watch and Katie that's
like asking me if I'm if I'm going to
breathe the only way that I will not get
the Apple watch is if hmm I don't I
don't know I will get the Apple watch I
will do whatever it takes to get it I
don't really remember all of the
different models that they have but I
really want the rose gold one and it's
gonna be interesting to see how they do
these orders because I really don't want
to have to camp out in front of the
Apple store again but I will do what I
have to do speaking of the Apple store
I'm just gonna tell you guys this
because I totally forgot I wanted to
mention it
in a video I have been doing this
campaign with prizeo and it was doing it
for the project for awesome so you got
to see that full video put a legal
description most important photo to
prizeo comm /i justine and we're giving
away a trip to one of you guys to come
to LA to meet me to go to the Apple
store and we're also giving away a ton
of other really fun prizes like t-shirts
and postcards and it's really cool
because not only are you guys donating
for a really good cause you'll actually
get a little something back and I'm so
excited to be helping out this
foundation is the Napa Center for Kids
Foundation and it's helping kids who
have disabilities who otherwise would
not have been able to get these
treatments because most of these
treatments have not been available in
the US the campaign is ending this week
and I really am hoping that we can meet
our goal and I think this is gonna be so
cool and if you guys do donate even if
it's just a dollar whatever you can do
we'll help and make sure you guys tweet
it to me because I will tweet you guys
back I will favor it and like wherever
you guys posted next question Kristina
minecraft or Call of Duty I cannot
choose I cannot choose between those
both both do I really hate pigs I have
never once said I hated pigs I love love
pigs they're my favorite animal what am
I gonna do another cooking video I'm
going to be doing one soon I was hoping
to do one here the sweet but I don't
think it's gonna happen it might happen
we'll see no promises but it will be
will be pretty soon but what should I
cook I don't even know like a New Year's
bundt cake or something one of my
favorite winter activities my favorite
winter activity is sitting inside and
drinking hot chocolate and just looking
at the snow wow that's nice I don't want
to be in it Laura is asking how I've
been feeling since Jane passed away Jane
was my kitty she was 18 years old and we
I mean is basically has been most all
not most of my life but a lot of the
life that I can remember
I named her Jane from the band Jane's
Addiction some of your eyes might not
even know who that is and I used to
change the lyrics around to be like Jane
says have you seen my mouse around
I can't remember Jamie is asking what's
the most unique location you've ever
vlog I've traveled a lot so I've got to
do some really cool vlogging experiences
like Iceland I've been to Alaska I pinch
uh Norway I mean do a lot of really fun
places they're probably the most Awkward
place that I've ever vlog is in an
airplane toilet weird is it me or could
you pull off like Elsa from frozen ah I
mean I probably could the only way that
I could do that is if we get a nice nice
little braid going on here I'm gonna be
really honest with you I have not seen
frozen the only thing that I know about
frozen is the song let it go let it go I
don't even know what they're letting go
like I have absolutely no idea like
what's the problem what's the issue I
don't know am i Elsa I quit like Lucas
why did you hit a creeper explode in
your office I just joined this new app
it's called story it's kind of cool I
saw Luis was on it and then I was like
all right I just download this app I
don't know much about it at all called
story sto RIE and you kind of make like
these little like video clips of your
day and then it just magically magically
puts it all together and it publishes
it's kind of cool and what I like the
most about it is it forces you if you
want to try to take a video like this it
says no turn the camera check it out if
you wanna follow me alight Justine I
found it from Luis he's he's probably
one of my favorite vloggers because he
does all kinds of really fun travel
stuff optic nadeshot wants to know who
would win in a game of Mario Kart you or
Jenna I think we might have to play a
game and find out I'm gonna say that I
would win but I might not win I don't
know more but Mandy once today I'll be
doing a book tour I will be doing a book
tour and I'm so so excited I've writing
this book has been kind of emotional
because you're reliving things from your
past that you might not want to relive
you're thinking about people that might
no longer be in your life whether they
have passed away or do your friendships
have dissolved and it's it's kind of
insane because you don't really want to
think of those things and I'm
kind of person that when something bad
happens I have to push it away from my
memory I push it away from my mind and I
don't think about it until obviously
something like this comes up so it's
it's kind of emotional and I'm really
excited for you guys to read it and
hopefully when I do the book tour I'll
get to meet you guys and you have
another question do i I don't that was
the last question so guys have any other
questions I do like to chat in the
comments so feel free to leave your
comments below and I will I will answer
them in comments reply forum yeah you
guys remember when I made the New Year's
resolution to do a draw my life well
okay well I didn't do it yet I'm sorry
we'll save that for 2015